so I'm obviously pumped about the Winter
Olympics are you guys pump dammit
hell yeah curling is dope as hell
Carlene Cosell I love ice skating
classic bobsled is did you make a
bobsled team competing this year yeah I
know there's a female Nigeria win or
lose we still lose all right I don't
know [ __ ] about the Winter Olympic I'm
gonna give you the craziest things that
have ever happened at the Winter
Olympics setting its 1964 Winter
Olympics in Austria they have mountains
in Australia wait winter Olivia okay
setting it's the 1964 Winter Olympics in
Austria okay so there's this Finnish
cross-country skier Aero manta and he is
just killing it it looks like a cross
between like Robert De Niro and mr. rod
number 69 thanks Tina have fun with that
Internet so he wins the 15 kilometer
cross-country skiing competition by 40
seconds it's a margin of victory that
still has not been able we're dumb
Americans how far is 15 kilometers oh
yeah good question yeah I'll have that
come up on the screen yeah also that
same year he won the 30 kilometer race
and he won it by a full minute blow the
competition a little competition out of
the water from 1960 to 1972 he won seven
medals how is he so good
right dope you think don't be they had
some testing done his red blood count
was 20% higher than the average male
athlete which led to suspicions that he
was doping like one of like a limitless
fill is that that Keanu Reeves movie
yeah
fast forward three decades and the
scientists tested 200 relatives and a
quarter of these relatives including man
taranta possess an uncommon genetic
mutation that triggers a rise in red
blood cells like super Austrians yeah
participant this genetic mutation made
man taranta highly sensitive to EPO
which is a hormone during exertion you
know when you're working out EPO
increases red blood cell production
which in turn increases muscle endurance
by contributing more oxygen you just got
more endurance so it wasn't even doping
it was just like it was natural doping
it's like a video gives in like I can
activate god mode increases your blood
why I'm doing God's Country let me set
the scene it's the 1948 Winter Olympics
in st. Moritz
so we're post-world War two not a lot of
pressure you can play games and not kill
each other yeah and then out steps the
US Olympic hockey team but then out
steps the other u.s. men's hockey team
there were two men talking words two
men's hockey teams they both thought
that they were the actual US Olympic
team so basically one team was sent by
the American Olympics Committee and the
other one was sent by the American
Hockey Association like how did they get
to the Olympics the International
Olympics committees like now like if you
both want to compete you neither you can
compete so the ice hockey federation
steps up and they're like we're gonna
declare the American Hockey Association
team the rightful US Olympic team so
they get to compete we had to have
uniforms meaning get to play like a bad
that's framed in somebody some grandpa's
house the other team after they get
rejected they just start going to the
real US Olympic hockey teams games and
they just start tackling the heck out of
there
and I don't know if they got into their
heads or anything but they ended up only
getting poor they missed the podium but
then all of it didn't matter because he
here later they just like disqualified
them completely like the hockey story
would have been like a good Will Ferrell
movie
it gives me dodgeball yeah dodgeball
means blades of glory all right so let
me set the scene
it's February 2002 in the little snow
town of Salt Lake City so everyone's
pretty hyped this year about the speed
skater Apolo Ohno he had like long hair
goatee bandana homeboy just went to
Michael's and got this bandana
it's the 1000 meters short track speed
skating final in 90 seconds begins he's
looking good it's neck and neck with
skaters from South Korea China and
Canada so they're all fighting for a
spot in that podium they're all round in
the final Bend and that Chinese skater
collides with Apollo like and they just
hit the ice and then they take everyone
down so no one else they all all of them
it's a huge wipeout yeah homeboy is all
the way yeah he's coming down
friggin people what do you guys think
happens Oh Paolo Toph was the guy who's
in fifth China no we haven't mentioned
him yet he's an Australian and
Australians don't even ice skate you
genius in Australia has never won an
Olympic gold medal at the Winter
Olympics but all of a sudden all these
people ran into each other this guy gets
the gold that guy's name was Steven
Bradbury this was actually a strategy
for him Bradbury had sustained serious
injuries earlier in his career including
incident in Montreal where a
competitor's skate went through his side
he needed a hundred eleven stitches
everybody has a whuppin on their feet
like what it's scary
people are like you're never going to
skate again year-and-a-half of rehab got
back out he goes to the Olympics but
he's like you know what it's possible
there could be
another accident I'm gonna hold back a
little you're wrong wait and see and
guess what he wait and saw Manso that go
look it up disappointed Apollo don't
feel bad for Apollo
oh no though because he got up after
falling and he skated in for a second so
he got the silver medal plus he won gold
for the 1500 meters so don't feel bad
for Apollo yeah we're gonna head grew up
you just take advantage I like that so
let's go over the lessons first lesson
some people genetically better sorry I
have to deal with that Batman is based
on a true story yeah in America is
greedy so sometimes the same two teams
still Olympics yeah yeah and then Arthur
lesson is sometimes you don't have to be
the best you can just almost be the best
it everybody in the top falls yeah
that's it everyone in the top falls baby
does this make you more pumped for the
Winter Olympics and you never know
what's gonna happen yeah I mean there's
some twins that are skating this year
they're supposed to be cool
[Music]